et
[Musique]
monsieur cloutier bonjour bienvenue à
moscou
nous sommes ravis que vous soyez avec
nous sur rtl
toujours quand nous avons eu l'occasion
de parler à de vrais experts
vous êtes un des meilleurs experts du
sujet en europe
donc laissez moi commencer avec ce que
tout le monde a en tête à l'heure
actuelle le variant mikron bien sûr avec
le temps les gens veulent vraiment
revenir à une vie normale mais voilà
qu'il y ait un nouveau variant des pays
ferment à nouveau leurs frontières de
nouvelles mesures sont introduites
réintroduite est plus difficile de
voyager
savons-nous de mikron à l'heure actuelle
sommes nous dans une meilleure situation
qu'en quand la pandémie a commencé ou
qu'il ya un an
on peut aborder les choses de manière
optimiste en constatons qu on ans est
nettement plus et que nous avons les
outils tous
concernant omikron cette année marion
qui est apparu il se diffuse nettement
plus rapidement mais je dis toujours que
nous n'avons pas à nous battre contre
invariants mais contre tous les variants
et le d'état est toujours dominant
ce que nous devons faire c'est mettre en
place ce que j'appelle les cinq
stabilisateur de pandémie le premier est
d'augmenter la couverture vaccinale
faire en sorte que ceux qui hésitent se
vaccine nombre le deuxième boost oust
boost c'est la meilleure protection
contre omicron le troisième doublé le
nombre de personnes portant des masques
en intérieur mais seuls 48% des gens en
europe et en asie centrale portent des
masques en main des valeurs le quatrième
a erré les salles de classe laissez les
écoles ouvertes mais le cinquième mettre
en place de nouveaux protocoles de
traitement repose au volant il faut
aussi une solidarité internationale
regardez l'afrique du sud botswana ils
ont agi correctement en faisant ce que
l' oms recommande en transmettant
immédiatement et en toute transparence
leurs informations bobkov et que
s'est-il passé ils ont été démotivés les
vols ont été supprimés
empêcher les vols fermer les frontières
cela ne va pas arrêter le virus
vous avez mentionné parmi ces cinq
éléments la vaccination
quel point sont valides les inquiétudes
selon lesquelles les vaccins pourraient
être inefficace face à omicron
bien aujourd'hui nous savons que les
vaccins sont toujours efficaces mais
pour la première et la seconde 12 peut
être un peu moins la protection revient
avec une troisième dose sow dogbo donc
le booster est très important
que savons-nous de mikron faste et se
diffuse plus vite il s'en prend à des
individus plus jeunes pourquoi parce
qu'ils font partie de ceux qui ne sont
toujours pas vaccinées troisièmement les
données préliminaires suggèrent qu'il
est moins virulent on ne sait pas encore
mais ça pourrait être un élément positif
des coûts totaux des éléments
qu'on ne sait pas c'est à quel point il
est mangée volant
il nous faut encore une semaine dix
jours et demi mais encore une fois cela
ne change pas notre stratégie nos que
nous fassions tout ce que nous pouvons
pour augmenter la couverture vaccinale
en europe et en asie centrale c'est la
priorité absolue tout en intensifiant en
parallèle les mesures de santé publique
se laver les mains garder ses distances
et s'y rendait rassemblement à d'autres
personnes vous éviter de mélanger et
faire des autotests pauthe il faut
confier certaines de ces mesures à la
population à la population est la
solution il faut responsabiliser les
gens faire des autotests et éviter les
rassemblements de masse cela ne va pas
aller bien loin semble-t-il pour ce qui
est spécifique à l'union européenne on a
vu toute une gamme d'aproz différentes
ce puisqu'on parle de stratégie
confinement d'un vacciner confinement
total des différentes règles quant à la
durée de l'efficacité des vaccins
pourquoi ne voyons-nous pas plus
d'uniformité de la part de ce bloc
particulier
je pense que l'uniformité s'est renforcé
avec le temps la procuration de vaccins
en commun par exemple a été un point
positif
mais il ya un manque d'uniformité dans
ce que j'appelle la cohérence de la
politique et cela désoriente les gens ça
n'aide pas à susciter la confiance
mais dans ma perspective je vois plus
large je regarde 53 pays et c'est pour
cela que l' oms promeut l'idée d'établir
un conseil sanitaire paneuropéen au plus
haut niveau pour avoir une uniformité
des politiques
même si la santé relève des compétences
nationales ce sont des décisions qui
doivent être prises par les pays
on en est loin de mettre en place une
telle organisation
mikron la volonté se fait plus fort je
pense par exemple avec les certificats à
kobe 19 si vous regardez le scout nick v
vaccine avons été informés par les
ministères de la santé et des affaires
étrangères que 70 pays acceptent déjà ce
certificat coville je pense qu'on va y
arriver
en parlant de spoutnik v le gouvernement
russe la question est de savoir quand ce
vaccin va être approuvée par
l'organisation mondiale de la santé est
particulièrement importante vous pouvez
vous nous donner des délais
nous avons entendu de la part d'un
certain nombre d'experts que cette
problématique a été politisée
rebondir sur votre dernier point avec
l'om est selon moi c'est ainsi depuis le
début la santé et notamment la question
des vaccins est au dessus de la
politique
d'aucuns ne doit jamais prendre en
compte le pays d'origine j'ai moi même
travaillé huit ans dans le pays je suis
très au fait des énormes capacités
intellectuelles et industriels pour la
production de vaccins la lie de vin
qu'il n'y a pas de politique en eau pour
le texte aux golden eye shield optimisme
je partage l'optimisme du président de
la fédération de russie que
l'inscription juste pique nique sur la
liste d'urgence de l' oms aura lieu
bientôt
octobre déziel en octobre de cette année
les documents légaux ont été signés par
le fonds russe d'investissements directs
n et non dans le premier trimestre de
l'année prochaine il y aura un suivi de
l'approbation par la direction de l'om a
cédé une fois que le dossier aura été
soumis un dossier ce qui aura lieu avant
la fin de l'année
problème
si vous voyez il ne me laisse même pas
le temps de donner mes excuses
ça va bien
derniers commentaires du porte parole du
kremlin et qui a dit que la russie ces
autorités elle n'avait à un moment pas
bien compris les demandes de l'om s mais
qu'il ne considérait pas que quelqu'un
était à blâmer en russie pour cela
je pense qu'il n'ya effectivement
personne à plat mais loupait c'est un
dossier complexe avec des critères très
stricts quant à la sécurité l'efficacité
et la qualité je pense que ce que nous
faisons maintenant c'est attendre la
suite mais le plus important est qu'un
gros travail a été abattu nous experts
étaient ici à moscou la semaine dernière
et les choses vont aller de l'avant pas
mais depuis le début j'ai toujours été
très optimistes contre sony gré aux
thématiques abordées
elle vous ne pouvez pas donner de délai
la première étape est d'obtenir le
dossier complet dossier et via
l'engagement que cela ait lieu avant la
fin de l'année dès le 4 janvier la
direction de l'om est ce à ce dieu fasse
que cela relève des responsabilités de
la direction
sera prête pour dialoguer et obtenir des
clarifications si nécessaire et venaient
ensuite procédé à une nouvelle
inspection
monsieur cloud google merci beaucoup
pour votre point de vue d'experts tout
le plaisir est pour moi
[Musique]